with Brett Kavanaugh is confirmation
still uncertain the Supreme Court begins
a new term without a ninth justice today
eight currently sit on the High Court
split between four conservatives and
four liberals now that sets up the
possibility of split decisions Jen
Crawford is at the Supreme Court Jim
good morning so tell us what is the
potential impact well it means that they
could tie if the cases are really
contentious or divisive and you know the
White House actually tried to avoid that
by a timeline that they they tried to
follow when they nominated Brett
Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court it was
expected he will go through his
confirmation hearings and then be
confirmed by the Senate in time to be on
place when the justices return for this
first Monday in October but of course it
didn't work out that way so now we're in
this prospect of a four to four tie and
some of the more divisive cases and we
saw that when the court went vacant or
when when that seat went vacant for 14
months after the death of Justice
Antonin Antonin Scalia but I don't think
it's going to happen right away because
here's the thing there are all these big
cases on the horizon you've got abortion
you've got gay rights you've got
immigration but right now they haven't
taken them yet so they've got kind of a
bunch of I don't want to say honors but
they're not the kind of cases that are
going to really divide the justices
divide the country so it's less likely
we're going to have a four to four tie
in some of these early on cases as the
term goes on that could well happen and
then if they split that lower court
decision would stand or they would
simply we argue it again when the new
justice joins the court Gail hey Jan
your honors really paints the picture we
get it thank you very much we all
understand what you know what I don't
want to call it that but you know but
but we get it we get it without be
talking about those as much exactly
Thank You Jan